The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: So while
we're waiting for the phone--
I mean, for the microphone,
a little bit of catching up
from the previous lecture--
on the slide over
there is a telescope.
So I don't want to spend
too much time on it.
You wanted to see the telescope
at least in one homework
problem of the previous set,
so you're familiar with it.
Then, once you
alluded to it earlier.
So it is kind of opposite than
the microscope in the sense
that, OK, both instruments are
similar because they magnify,
but they magnify what?
In the case of a microscope,
we see very small detail.
Thank you.
We've got a new battery now,
so we're back in business.
So in the microscope,
the object appears small
because it is
physically very small,
and it is available nearby.
That is a definition
of a microscope.
In the case of a
telescope, the object
appears small, not because
it is physically small,
but it is-- but because
it is very far away.
So for example, a star--
a star is humongous,
and it may be several thousand
times bigger than the Earth,
but it appears very small
because it is also maybe
thousands of light years away.
So this is the situation
where we typically--
where we use a telescope.
So you see there the function
of the telescope here.
So if this is the
case of a telescope
with an object with a finite
location, so in this case,
the object is physically big.
It appears small
because it is far away.
So the telescope,
in this case, it
is actually very similar
to the microscope,
to the way it works.
It creates an image of this
object in the following sense,
that each point in the object
becomes a parallel ray bundle
at the output of the telescope.
So therefore, the
observer-- again,
recall that the
final, final image
is produced by the lens of the
observer's eye on the retina.
So the eye of the observer picks
up this parallel ray bundle
and focuses it on the retina.
Now, if you extend
the rays backwards
through the final
eyepiece of the telescope,
you can see that the
telescope actually
is creating a virtual image
that is magnified with its back
to the original object.
And that's why-- that's
how the telescope magnifies
this remote object.
It is more common
to use a telescope
as shown in the second case,
where the object is actually
at infinity.
And that is the classical case
of a telescope, where now,
instead of having
spherical waves arriving
from points in the object,
now I have plane waves.
So to a good approximation,
to an excellent approximation,
star is located at infinity.
But not necessarily--
even terrestrial objects
that are located, say,
more than 100 meters,
so a kilometer
away, they satisfy
this approximation quite well.
So they produce these
almost parallel ray bundles.
So the telescope, in this
case, it is afocal in the sense
that the output of the
scalar telescope, again you
produce a parallel ray bundle.
And the reason, of
course, is that you
want the observer to form an
image with unaccommodated eye.
That means that still the
image must be at infinity
so that the eye--
without any strain, the eye
can focus it to the retina.
And since that is the case,
it means that the total--
now, let's be a
little bit careful
with the terminology-- the total
power of the telescope is zero.
That is, the telescope
has no optical power.
Its focal length is infinity.
However, it does have
magnifying power.
What a telescope does
in this case, the angle
between a chief
ray and the axis,
the telescope
magnifies this angle.
And this is now by
definition the magnification
of the telescope,
and you can see
that by virtue of
magnifying this angle,
the telescope also magnifies
the final real image that
will be produced on the retina.
And in order to be afocal--
this was the topic
of the homework
that I gave you guys a few--
I don't know-- I think
it was two weeks ago.
In order to be afocal, the
distance between the two lenses
must equal the sum
of the focal length.
It is very easy to convince
yourselves in this case
that an instrument such as
this one, then in the imaging,
in the matrix of the instrument,
the matrix will look like this.
And it will have a 0
in the 1, 2 element.
In the first row, second
column, it will have a 0.
If that is the case-- whoops--
if that is the case,
then it is called afocal.
So by satisfying
this condition, d
equals f objective
plus f eyepiece, we
ensure that this is the case.
So there's a number of
different types of telescopes.
I just picked one here.
The textbook lists all of them.
There is the Keplerian,
Galilean, astronomical
telescope.
They all have different
combinations of lenses.
I picked one here that
is composed exclusively
of mirrors, and it is
very common actually
in observation--
in observatories.
It is called the Cassegrain.
It is also the same
type that, if you
go to the Discovery
Store, for example,
and buy a telescope for
your nephew or your niece,
this is the type.
You look at it, and,
you know, the tube
is oriented horizontally, and
you look at it from the top.
And this is the schematic here.
The object, or the
sky, is on this end,
and you place your eye this way.
So the telescope itself
consists of a large first mirror
that functions as the
primary, and then there's
a second mirror.
So if you look at the--
from this side, if you
look into the telescope,
you will see a small
block in the front face
of the instrument.
So that is the secondary mirror.
So the combination of primary
and secondary-- of course,
you use two of them to get
even higher magnification,
and the combination
is the objective.
And then, there's
an eyepiece, which
is where you stick
your eye, and you
see the-- you see
the image of the sky.
So this is composed
purely of mirrors.
So last time, we're going to
call this kind of instrument
catoptric.
Then, there's another
type of telescope.
Actually, it's not a telescope.
It's a kind of a method for
correcting optical systems
called Schmidt--
Schmidt telescope or
Schmidt optical system.
So let me say why you use this.
So you recall that the ideal
mirror surface to give perfect
focusing of an object at
infinity is actually parabolic.
Now, suppose that we
cannot make a parabola,
so we have to make a sphere
instead of a parabola.
Well, in that case, a
little bit of thought
will convince yourself
that the sphere, because it
is more highly curved than
the parabola near the edges,
away from the
paraxial region, it
will actually bend the rays
that are far from the axis.
They will bend more
than they should.
So the result is the failure
to reach perfect focus.
This is what we
have already seen,
and we'll call it
spherical aberration.
So Schmidt basically
came up with an idea
to correct this
spherical aberration
by sticking a slightly--
a glass surface at
the front pupil here.
He put a glass surface
which is slightly shaped.
It has toroidal shape,
and the purpose--
I don't know if you can
see it in the image.
It was a-- perhaps I should
have exaggerated more.
It is too subtle.
But what it does is
it takes this ray
and sends it slightly higher,
so this kind of functions
like a negative lens, actually.
You can think of it this
way, with a very small power.
And then, because
this hits the surface
at a different point
with a different angle,
then, basically, by engineering
the shape of the surface here,
you can make sure that
most-- that all of the rays
will actually meet ideally
at the focal point.
So this is a very simple
way to correct for this.
I don't know if it is
simple, but, anyway, it
is a way to correct for
spherical aberration.
So this is called
catadioptric because it
contains a reflector, as
well as a refractive element.
So according to our terminology,
that's what we call it.
So that's all I had to
say about telescopes.
Are there any questions or--
either about telescopes
or microscopes
or any of the optical
systems that we saw?
So next, I'm going to
shift gears a little bit,
and I'm going to expand
on the very last topic
that we saw, the
topic of aberration.
So we saw quite extensively--
we mentioned several times
this spherical aberration.
It turns out it is
not the only one,
and we'll see a number of
different types of aberrations
today.
So to do a little
bit of organization
and classification, we start by
classifying them as two types.
One is chromatic, and this we
have also seen in the past,
in the context of
a prism primarily.
And it is due to the fact
that the index of refraction
has a variation with wavelength.
So if you apply the lens maker's
formula, or any of those,
in order to design an element
with a given focal length
at the given wavelength,
you have no guarantee
that the focal length
will be the same
at the different wavelength.
That fact is called
chromatic aberration.
Again, this comes
from a Greek word.
I had to do this, and I sound
like this movie, My Big Fat
Greek Wedding, but since I'm
Greek, I guess it is natural.
So chroma-- in Latin, this
would spell the chroma,
with the accent here.
It means color in Greek.
So that's where the term
chromatic comes from.
The second time-- or for the
second type of aberration
is called geometrical.
And there's a long definition
here, but I will go back to it,
and perhaps this long
definition will make more sense.
Let me start with
chromatic because this
is easy to deal with--
OK, not easy to deal with,
but it is easy to understand.
So as I said, we have
seen this type of plot
before, where the horizontal
axis is the wavelength.
The vertical axis is
the index of refraction.
And forget this dashed
line for a moment.
Just look at the solid lines.
So these are the
index of refraction,
this function of wavelength,
for different glasses.
You have seen this before
in the context of a prism.
This is, of course, a disaster.
It means that if you have
a lens like this one, which
you designed for a
certain focal length,
say, somewhere in the
middle of the spectrum,
say, near yellow,
then this means that--
well, as you can see, the index
in the red wavelength for sort
of normal materials-- this
is actually called normal
dispersion--
the index is smaller
at the red wavelengths.
So if you remember the
lens maker's formula,
smaller index means that
the focal length is what?
OK, the lens maker's
formula says that 1 over f
equals n minus 1, the
difference in radii.
So if n goes down, it means
that 1 over f goes down.
It means that the f goes up.
So it means that the
focal length is longer.
And this is also what you see
in this picture over here.
You'll see that if you
have a white light coming
from infinity, you'll see
that the red rays focus
at the longer distance
than the blue rays.
So that is the evidence
of chromatic aberration,
and it turns out there's
a way of correcting it,
which is to stick two
lenses, one of them with a--
that is a positive lens and
the other a negative lens.
And first of all, they have to--
the two lenses have to have
a slightly different indices.
Otherwise, it wouldn't
even make sense, right?
Then this would be
just one element.
So they have different
indices, different dispersion
probably, so one can pick, for
example, between these glasses.
You could pick one
lens out of this one,
another out of this one.
This is how one designs
this kind of element.
And then, the way to understand
it is because one of them
tries to focus the rays.
The other, because
it is negative,
it will try to
actually defocus them.
You can imagine how
one can compensate
the action of the positive
lens with the action
of the negative
lens and eventually
cancel, or at least
approximately cancel,
a chromatic aberration
over a relatively
long range of wavelengths.
I used to give you this
problem as a homework.
I don't do it anymore.
But, anyway, it is a fairly
straightforward thing to do.
And if you go over
the textbook, there's
an entire section where
he tells you in detail how
this kind of thing can be done.
Conceptually, it is very simple.
All you do is you
balance the focal length.
So you basically make sure
that the composite has
a focal length that is
the nominal focal length,
and then you balance
the chromatic
by use of the two
elements of the composite.
The geometrical
aberrations, they're
more interesting because,
conceptually, they're actually
much richer than chromatic, and
also, algebraically, they're
much more difficult to handle.
So people have come up with
all kinds of clever tricks
in order to understand and
express geometric aberrations.
So again, let me remind
you that at the exit
of an optical instrument,
the ideal wavefront should
be spherical.
So this is the dashed
line over here.
If you draw normals to this
spherical wavefront, of course,
there will be the radii of
the corresponding sphere,
and they will meet at
the center of the sphere.
So if I actually produce
a spherical wavefront,
then I can expect a
perfect geometrical focus
at the center of that
spherical wavefront.
So the problem, of course,
these are optical instruments,
as we saw repeatedly in a
number of cases in the past,
including the
spherical reflectors,
spherical refractors,
and so on and so forth,
they don't produce spherical
wavefronts at the action.
They produce wavefronts
that, in general, may
be some complicated surface.
So in this case,
you see the eye is--
of course, are exaggerated--
I made it terribly
aberrated, and this
is the solid line over here.
So the difference between the
actual aberrated wavefront
and the ideal wavefront, which
is, of course, spherical,
this difference is by
definition the aberration.
So I tried to be
fairly loyal here.
So I-- again, this
is a cartoon, but I
took the difference between the
solid line and the dashed line,
and this is what you would get.
Typically, you measure it
in optical path length,
and it doesn't have
to be very dramatic.
The vertical axis here can be
as small as a few wavelengths,
and that is often
sufficient to destroy
the quality of the image
formation in an optical system.
In fact, the book has the story
of the Hubble telescope, which
is kind of famous,
or I should say
infamous study of a disaster,
and heroic, in optical design.
The telescope was sent to
space with a serious error
in the design--
actually, in the
assembly, that caused
a huge spherical aberration.
And then, they had to send
another spacecraft to fix it,
and so on.
Anyway, they actually
succeeded, which is impressive.
But, anyway, so what the book
says is that the error was--
actually turned out to be--
I think it was half
a wavelength or so.
Whatever that had was
sufficient to destroy
the quality of the images that
were beamed from the telescope.
So one has to be very, very
careful in this business.
So as you can
imagine, if you tried
to express this kind
of complicated surface
or its difference
from a sphere, you
will probably get a very nasty
trigonometric expression,
so for a number of reasons.
One of them has to
do with the ability
to compute
analytically, which is
kind of an old-fashioned problem
because now we have computers.
So that's one reason,
but the second reason,
because of the desire
to get intuition
about how these things work.
People normally
express aberrations
in the form of a Taylor series.
And, of course,
you are dealing now
in-- this is a surface, not
just a curve, as I show here.
The Taylor series
is high dimensional.
You actually have many terms for
each order in the Taylor series
expansion.
So these terms are actually
grouped into orders,
and the aberrations that--
and the terms that we
consider as a first step
in an optical system are
the third-order aberrations,
that are also known
as Seidel aberrations.
And, of course, the
second-order aberrations
disappear because we assume
rotationally symmetric optics.
That kills all the second-order
terms in the Taylor series
by definition.
And the first-order aberration
is actually only one,
and that is the focus.
So the first-order aberration
is actually paraxial.
It is something we've
already considered.
And then, it is the
third order that we
deal with in optical design.
So there's all-- after you
go through all the symmetries
and all that, it turns out that
the further the aberrations,
it's five of them.
One we've already
encountered, it is spherical,
and the other four are
coma, astigmatism, curvature
of field, and distortion.
And what you see here is
the aberration wavefronts,
so this probably
doesn't mean very much.
What we'll do next
is we'll actually
see a ray diagram of
all of these aberrations
and what they look like.
So the spherical, these diagrams
are straight out of the book.
We have seen actually
several times,
and the way spherical aberration
looks like, it basically
happens when the rays that
are away from the axis,
they receive more curvature than
rays that are near the axis,
or more or less.
So in both of
these cases, you'll
get the situation where the
rays from away from the axis,
they focus before or
after the paraxial focus.
And it is interesting,
the way-- but
if you look at this
kind of system,
you wonder what exactly
is the focal spot?
And that's not an easy
question to answer,
so if you look at the
marginal ray over here,
the size of the
beam that you create
is, of course, defined
by the marginal ray.
So you see that the marginal
ray kind of focuses here, then
starts to focus less.
Then it reaches a
minimum size, and then
starts to expand again because
now this aberrated ray takes
over.
So there's a minimum width
in this optical beam,
in this aberrated
optical beam to produce,
and that is called the least--
the circle of least confusion.
It is kind of a compromise
to see whether this system is
approximately in focus.
Another thing that I want to
emphasize from this diagram
is that, as you can see, near
the edge here of this bundle,
there is a congruence
of rays that approach.
So if you-- this-- you can
only see a few rays here,
but if you imagine that you
fill up the space with rays,
then you would
see that you would
get a very tight intersection
of successive rays that
trace a curve here.
This curve is called
a caustic, and, again,
that's another Greek word.
[GREEK] means
something that burns.
And the reason it is called
caustic or the reason it
alludes--
the word alludes to burning
is because this congruence
of rays, if you were
to put a piece of paper
there, if you wanted
to put an element,
it would create and increase
the intensity of light
near the edge of this bundle.
And therefore, it would
cause, presumably,
elevated temperature since
you have more light energy,
and that might actually
result in burning.
Caustics are very
interesting things.
I will say a little bit
more perhaps next time
about caustics, but
they occur often when
you deviate from a perfect
spherical wavefront.
When you pick
different wavefronts
other than spherical,
these caustics
have a tendency to occur.
And there's a very beautiful
mathematical theory
that describes that.
It is a little bit
advanced, so we're not
going to-- it is kind of
beyond the scope of this class.
But I thought since also
the book has mentioned it,
I thought it would be
interesting to point out
the existence of this caustic.
When it comes to
spherical aberration,
there's only several
things one can
do in order to control
the spherical aberration.
One is the actual
shape of the lens.
If you'll go back to
the lens maker formula,
this one over here--
I've already written it--
you can see very easily that you
can get the same focal length
with a number of different
combinations of radii
for the front and the
back surface of the lens.
So from the paraxial
point of view,
it makes no difference
whether you pick--
for example, whether
you pick a plano-convex,
or whether you pick
a biconvex lens,
or whether you pick a meniscus,
and so on, from the paraxial
point of view, they're
all the same because--
as long as you have
the same focal length.
However, because this
theory now-- we've
gone beyond the
paraxial approximation--
this theory is non-paraxial.
Actually, the shape factor of
the lens makes a difference.
And then, forget the
definitions here.
This plot is the
most interesting one,
where you can see
different lens shapes.
This is a meniscus, kind of
that the-- a convex meniscus.
Then, this is plano-convex.
This is biconvex,
again plano-convex,
but flipped the
other way around,
and then a concave meniscus.
And this plot was
computed so that all
of these different
shapes, they have
the same paraxial focal length,
but on the vertical axis,
you kind of see the amount
of spherical aberration
that you receive.
And you can see that it is
very different, of course,
and it actually has a minimum.
It is not quite zero,
but it is a minimum,
and the minimum occurs typically
near the plano-convex shape
for an object of infinity.
So why is that?
Well, the reason is--
this is kind of nicely
illustrated by another diagram
that I stole from your textbook.
If you place the
plano-convex lens such
that its flat surface
faces the plane wave coming
from infinity, then,
basically, refraction
occurs only at this
spherical interface.
So you have no hope.
You will get very strong
spherical aberration
because, as we learned
earlier, this spherical surface
is very far from ideal
as a focusing element.
So this case is very
highly aberrated.
Now, you can do a
very simple thing.
You can flip the lens so
that this spherical wave
meets this spherical--
I'm sorry-- so
that the plane wave
meets this spherical surface.
If you do that,
then you actually
get refraction to
occur in two steps.
And because the
first step produces
an aberrated spherical wave,
but the second step also
incurs some spherical aberration
because of the nonlinearity
in the Snell's law, it turns
out that, in this case,
the second surface, not
exactly, but closely
compensates the
spherical aberration.
And you get a much better
focusing quality over here.
So this is very good, practical
advice that we give to the sort
of first-year graduate students
when they go to the laser lab,
is that when you have--
when you try to focus a plane
wave, you always orient--
but for A, you use a
plano-convex lens, not
a biconvex, and B, that
you place it in this way,
so that the spherical
surface of the lens
meets the planar wavefront.
And, of course, it goes-- it
goes the other way around.
If you have a point source, and
you want to collimate it, then
again, you have to
make sure basically
you can reverse
the rays over here.
And you have to
orient the lens so
that the planar part of the
lens faces the point source.
So this is an example of doing
a very simple trick in order
to not quite
eliminate, but reduce
the spherical aberration.
It turns out that-- yes?
Push the button, please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: He didn't
push the button.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: In that
graph, how did they
actually measure the spherical
aberration in different lens
shapes?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
So the way to-- thank you.
I should have mentioned that.
So you can characterize
a spherical aberration
based on one of these
parameters here.
One is-- so it's called
the longitudinal spherical
aberration, and
it is the distance
on axis between
the paraxial focus
and the focal point of the
last-- of the marginal ray.
Right?
Another way to do it
is to basically measure
the size of the least confusion.
So any of these-- if you
think about it, all of these
are proportional to
each other, so you
can put any of these quantities
on the vertical axis here.
I'm not sure what he did here.
I think it says
axial here, so it was
the longitudinal distance here.
And I thank you.
I should have mentioned that.
This way of characterization
is common for all
of the aberrations that we'll
see in the next two slides.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Button.
AUDIENCE: We knew
which is the lengths.
Do they specify paraxial
or focal length,
or circle of least
confusion as a f?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
That is a real good question.
If it is a sort
of high-end lens,
it should be well corrected.
So then, what it will specify
is actually the least confusion
focal end, but it is
pretty close to paraxial.
If it is a poor lens, then
most likely what they specify
is the paraxial focus, and
then it is kind of up to you
to position it.
Any other questions?
The--
AUDIENCE: In the previous--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi, George.
In the previous slides,
what is the curve
in the third and previous at--
hold on.
Yeah, what is the curve
in the third graph?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: The
curve in the third graph?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So the vertical axis is H,
and horizontal axis was--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: This one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: I
don't remember, actually.
I think it is the--
I suppose it is the amount
of spherical aberration
as a function of
position in the field.
I'm not really sure.
Maybe you can check that.
Actually, I have the book.
You can check the book, huh?
This came-- is
directly from the book.
I think it is the amount
of spherical aberration.
It makes sense because-- here.
Any other questions?
So it turns out that
what we said before,
and, actually, Colin made that
point when I was discussing
ellipsoid, that the fractals
and so on and so forth,
and what we said before, that
a spherical surface produces
spherical aberration,
it is not always true.
There is one condition where
a spherical surface does not
produce spherical aberration.
And this condition
is given here.
That's another diagram I got--
that I got from the book.
And you can see here,
basically, the condition
says that if the radius
of this field is R,
the index of refraction
of this field is n2.
The index of refraction
outside this sphere is n1,
and you place a point source
at the distance R n1 over n2.
Then, of course, the point
source is inside this sphere.
If you think about it,
this is a negative lens.
It will produce a virtual image.
This virtual image
is located over here,
and it is free of
spherical aberration.
I will not prove this.
This is actually in the book.
It is given as a
problem in the textbook,
and the problems in
the textbook are solved
at the end of the textbook.
That's why I never assign
problems from the textbook.
And anyway, you can
look at it afterwards.
It is a very simple
geometrical proof of this one.
So we'll skip it here.
But the point of this is
that there is actually
a single combination of image--
I'm sorry-- of
object image pairs,
for which the spherical
aberration is canceled
for this spherical surface.
And again, I want to emphasize
that if you place the object
point elsewhere,
it will still form
an image in the paraxial sense.
This lens will remain
a lens, but it will not
be free of spherical aberration.
It will only be free if this
condition here is satisfied.
And actually, this
distance that I mentioned
is from the center
of this sphere.
All right, so the
reason for that--
so this now has a
number of implications.
For example, this is one
reason why meniscus lenses are
very popular in photography,
or at least in very
old-fashioned cameras
that were very expensive.
Now, we're talking about cameras
in the '20s and '30s, you know,
the type of camera that
the cameraman would
go under a black hood and
then going, and then click.
And, you know, the family
would be sitting with the--
whatever, with the
children, all that stuff.
And so these cameras, they would
typically use a single meniscus
lens, and the reason was exactly
that the meniscus, at least
if you designed it for
the typical distance--
remember, again, this was a
camera for a photography shop.
So it has-- you
can kind of predict
the location of the object
because the camera's already
always sitting in the same
distance from the-- wherever
you place the family to
take the family picture.
And then, in that case, you
can engineer the meniscus
to minimize this
spherical aberration
for this particular distance.
It turns out the
meniscus also has
some other interesting
properties,
but I will not go into that.
So of course, in that case, you
cannot really put the family
in glass, so you're going to
have exactly this situation
over here.
But, nevertheless, if
you think about it,
you don't need-- you know, you
can satisfy this condition,
even if you have two
spherical surfaces, provided
that, as you go from
one surface to the next,
you have to satisfy
the same condition.
It is the same condition that
you have to satisfy twice.
And I forgot to
mention, this condition
is called the
aplanatic condition.
Actually, that, I don't know
why it is called aplanatic,
but it sounds like a--
you know, Colin, why--
where that comes from?
Aplanatic means non-planar.
It makes no sense
at all, but, anyway,
that's what they call it.
And it is also used in
oil immersion microscopy.
In this case, we mentioned that.
Actually, it was also a topic
of one of the homeworks.
Oil immersion means that you
put the liquid, the droplet,
between the objective and
the sample in the microscope.
And in this case,
again, you can kind of
make sure that when you apply
the aplanatic condition--
because, again,
in the microscope,
you have very good control over
the distance between the exit
pupil and the object.
And you can make sure that
the aplanatic condition is
satisfied for this
particular distance,
and you can use the index
of refraction of the oil
in order to satisfy the
aplanatic condition.
So now, that's the
case where you exactly
cancel the spherical aberration,
so it is very interesting.
It is different than
the previous case.
Here, we exactly
cancel it by using
this particular condition.
The next aberration I
wanted to discuss is coma.
So coma is different than
spherical in the sense
that spherical occurs even if
you have on-axis incidence.
Coma actually occurs for
off-axis incident rays.
So this is the typical image,
or the typical sort of depiction
of coma that you see in books.
Again, you have a plane
wave coming from infinity,
but it is incident
at an angle of focus.
So it is likely quite
possible that you
might have spherical aberration
as well in this case.
But in this
particular case, we're
only concerned
for the aberration
due to the fact that you are off
axis, and that is called coma.
So if you work out sort of
the non-paraxial imaging
for this case, you will discover
that at the focal plane,
sort of up to here,
what you see is
a cross-section of the system
in the meridional plane.
And this is what you would see
as a front view on the imaging
plane, and it turns out that
you can also see it here.
This is perhaps
a better picture.
It looks like a
teardrop, and this is
where the term coma comes from.
It is not a condition
that you enter
after a very serious
accident, but it
is rather from the
punctuation symbol, a comma.
In old-fashioned books, kind
of the comma looks like this.
So ah, I don't know
how good my drawing is,
but this teardrop
shape is kind of
reminiscent of the
punctuation, a comma.
So this is what it looks like.
And now, the geometry of this
is a little bit complicated.
You can basically
calculate the shape
of the coma in the
meridional plane
and the sagittal plane,
perpendicular to that.
So the meridional
plane is this one,
the one that you
see over here that
is-- if you take the
plane of incidence,
it is the plane that cuts
through the center of the lens.
And then if you
rotate by 90 degrees,
that would be the
sagittal plane.
So according, because
we are off axis,
the two are not
symmetric anymore.
On axis, they are symmetric,
but off axis, they're not,
so that's what gives rise to
the strongly asymmetric nature
of the coma.
And it turns out, if you
do some simple geometry,
you find out that the
length of this comatic shape
along the tangential,
the meridional plane, it
turns out to be three
times the length
along the sagittal plane.
So this follows from geometry.
To be honest, I never quite
went through the derivation
of this one, but,
anyway, someone did it.
And these derivations,
by the way,
they have a way of
becoming very complicated,
even when they give
very simple results,
like this case over here.
Whether we'd like to--
there's a few things
I would like to say about coma.
One is, of course,
that it also depends
on the shape of the lens.
So here you see what this
spherical aberration and coma
plotted for lenses of
the same focal length,
but different shape factor.
And you can see that,
fortuitously, there's
a region over here, where,
above the spherical-- actually
the coma is
completely eliminated,
and this spherical
is close to zero.
So this means that this
is a good design point,
if you want to
simultaneously minimize coma
and this spherical aberration.
Now, you might wonder--
let me skip for a
moment the discussion
of the bottom figure over here.
I'll come back to it.
But you may wonder how it can
be that coma is completely
eliminated.
It turns out that--
and, again, this is something
I will give without proof.
It turns out that there is a
condition that, indeed, you
can cancel coma.
So this is called
the sine condition.
Sine, now, this is
not a Greek word.
It is actually a
Latin word, [LAUGHS]
and it is the same sine as the
sine we have in [INAUDIBLE]..
And this requires a
little bit of explanation,
so we'll do that, and
then we'll quit for today.
So the sine condition
follows from another result
for the optical sine theorem.
Interestingly, for those of you
who are mechanical engineers
and know thermodynamics,
this theorem
was proven by a kind of a hero
of thermodynamics, Clausius.
There was-- I think there's
some kind of something
called Clausius Inequality,
or something like that.
It's a very big, important
result in thermodynamics.
So he proved it first,
and then two other people
associated with optics more
closely, Abbe and Helmholtz,
they derived it
independently 10 years later.
So what is it this theorem say?
Well, here's again the
geometry of an optical system.
We use the notation alpha as
before to denote the angles,
and y--
for some reason, the
book uses y, not x,
to denote the elevation of rays.
So this is not an exact
result. It is not quite axial,
but it says that if you
satisfy the imaging condition,
then the index of refraction,
the ray elevation, and the sine
of the ray angle
in the object space
are the same as the
product of this-- actually,
I should've said the
product of the three
is the same as the product
in the image space.
So you can see these quantities
over here, all of them,
a sub i--
I'm sorry-- this is a sub i, a
sub o, and so on and so forth.
Why is this significant now?
If you take the ratio of
y at the image plane--
so this is y sub
i over y sub o--
that ratio is the magnification.
So you see a problem here.
The problem is that
if you calculate
the ratio from this
quantity, the ratio
would turn out to be what?
I could do-- turn out to
be something like n i--
sine alpha i over n
object sine alpha object.
And because of the
presence of the sines
here, you can very easily deduce
that the magnification is not
the same.
The magnification
that you had depends
on the size of the
object, which, of course,
very annoying.
We did not see that in the
paraxial approximation,
but, of course, this
is non-paraxial.
That's why it happens,
but it is very annoying.
It is-- and it is the
reason why coma happens.
You can also see it over here.
You can see a very-- you can
see sort of the different rays.
They attempt to reach-- to
focus at different locations
in the image plane.
So that's the reason.
So the sine theorem says, boy,
if I could actually make--
I'm sorry-- if I could
actually make this ratio,
sine alpha in the object
over sine alpha in the image,
if I could make equal to
the corresponding paraxial
quantities, then
I would be happy
because then the
magnification would
be the same, independent
of object elevation.
And therefore, I
would be free of coma.
So that is the sine theorem.
So basically, the reason
coma can be eliminated here,
it is because, for this
particular lens configuration,
the sine theorem is
actually satisfying.
So you basically get a complete
elimination of the coma.
So unless there's any questions,
I think we should quit here,
and we'll continue
with the remaining
aberrations on Wednesday.
AUDIENCE: George--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --can I make
a comment about the--
I've been thinking about
this aplanatic word
that you mentioned.
If you go back a couple
of slides to the--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Maybe far?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That-- yeah, that one will do.
I think that-- now I'm thinking
where that word comes from.
I've never really thought
about it before, but the--
that, of course, the
aplanatic condition
will be satisfied not
just at one point,
but on a complete
sphere, with center
at the center of the
spherical surface.
And the perfect image will be
formed on another sphere, also
with its center at the center
of the spherical surface.
So I think maybe that's
why it says not plane.
It's because the image
on a spherical surface
is going to be formed perfectly
on another spherical surface.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah,
because with a virtual surface,
as we'll see a little bit later.
Yeah.
Yep, that makes sense.
AUDIENCE: Hmm.